experts say firearms should always be
locked away when they're at home mary
jane bellies are joining us live now in
the newsroom with more safety reminders
mary jane
well many families have a gun in the
home as a means for sport or protection
but experts i spoke with say that also
means protecting the ones you love with
education on gun safety
[Music]
for retired henderson police officer
david colemeyer he says it takes more
than just hiding your guns to keep kids
safe it's all about education too he
says to keep firearms out of sight and
locked away this also includes hiding
bullets in a separate location as the
father of three young kids he says it's
important to teach your children what to
do if they find a gun and the
consequences of what could happen if
they pick it up if you see a firearm not
to touch it to tell a parent or even
maybe notify the police calling 911 the
emergency number or calling 3-1-1 the
non-emergency you know maybe going on to
google and
showing firearms or looking up some
different stories and using it as a
reference point that children have died
kohlmeyer says it's also best to have
these conversations with others if your
child is visiting a friend's home ask
the adults whether they have guns and if
so whether these are securely and safely
stored make sure you know your child's
friend and the friend's parents before
your child goes to their home and always
make sure a trusted adult will be at the
house while your child is visiting
now colemier says be sure to go over and
think about all the aspects when
considering buying a gun in your
household or if you already own a gun
you can also buy gun locks online at
we're at a gun shop reporting in the
newsroom mary jane ballisa live local
now